[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's what YouTube plot is
and in this grammar of Graphics we have
to define the data and the data has to
be in the structure of a data frame
there's lots of ways of holding data in
R you can hold it as a vector as a
matrix as a list
but it has to actually be a data frame
to use with this particular package
and this is probably the most popular
package for doing Graphics now in our
and then a coordinate system everything
we're going to do today is a 2d
coordinate system there's going to be an
x-axis and a y-axis if you were going to
create Maps or you're going to look at
pie charts for example you might use
polar coordinates map projections but
we're just going to stick with straight
old 2D coordinate systems but certainly
ggplot can handle these other systems
geodes geomes are the objects that we're
going to
place on our graph whether that's points
or lines or bars or error bars or
bubbles but any physical you know
representation we're going to stick on
our graph we're going to call those
geomes for geometric objects
and then the Aesthetics are basically
the mapping between characteristics of
our data and visual aspects of our graph
so for example we may make salary
represented by the height
on the y-axis and years of experience be
the
position on the vertical Act of the
horizontal axis X and then we might for
example say that the color of the we may
use points on our graph and the color of
those points will be mapped to whether
the person is male or female
and the size of the points might be
mapped to
um whether or not they're in an applied
or a theoretical field so Aesthetics
refer to the visual characteristics in
the graph that are mapped specifically
to variables in our data set and that's
different than just assigning a value
uh
uh to uh an aspect of the graph where I
can make uh the points blue
but that's not an aesthetic that's just
a value that's assigned an aesthetic
refers to the link between a variable
and our data and what you're seeing in
the graph and then scales so for example
I might say I want the size of a point
to represent years of experience how
we're going to relate the size or the
point to the years of experience what's
that formula basically from going from
years of experience to size of a point
and that's the scale most of this will
be handled for you automatically the
stats many of the aspects of graphs
within ggplot involve different
statistics that are coordinated so you
might add a trend line a line of best
fit and that can get specified
automatically it could specify different
kinds of Statistics to graph
facets are what tough to call small
multiples so let's say that I wanted to
have a graph relating years of
experience to salary
and I wanted to do it separately for
males and females but I wanted to do it
in one graph two graphs side by side
those would be called facets one of the
things that are what ggplot2 is so great
at is creating these small multiples or
facets and we'll see that in a minute so
these are the things that make up
the grammar of graphics and the things
we're going to be most concerned about
are the data the Aesthetics and the
geomes
when we specify those we'll get a nice
graph and then if we want to tweak it
we'll work with some of these other
things so let's just look at a simple
graph now how many assistant associate
and full professors do we have in this
data set
and so we start with the ggplot command
and we specify the data frame
you know what's holding our data in this
case salaries
and then we specify an aesthetic
you know what do we want to have on our
x-axis
and we're going to put rank so we'll put
assistant associate and full Professor
here
okay so we'll say x equals Rank and we
could say y equals count but that's
really automatically assumed
uh when you're creating a bar chart
if we had just said the ggplot we'd have
an empty graph but now we specified that
we want bars and we use the genome bar
function to do that
and that gives us our bar chart
and in ggplot the default is kind of a
gray background with white lines but
we're going to be able to change all of
this you know very easily
and notice the genome bar is a function
and as a function it can take
parameters itself some commoner
parameters would be with you know how
wide you want these bars to be
fill what color do you want these bars
to be and then color the border around
the bars
and then the position we'll see examples
of position in a minute
to use ggplot it's really helpful to
understand the difference between fill
and color to ggplot
color is the color for
uh geometric objects that have no area
so a point for example if theoretically
has no area a line has no area the the
border around a bar has no area so if I
said color equals blue I wouldn't get
blue bars I would get black bars that
had a blue border around the edges
so whenever you see color in ggplot2
it's talking about
Minds points
and borders
Phil is the color that you want for
areas like bars like other things we'll
see in in amenity too we could also
in our AES I should have mentioned this
AES stands for aesthetic and within the
aesthetic function this is where you put
the link between your data and the
aspects you can see so here what we've
said is we want to link rank to the
x-axis
we don't have to specify the y-axis
because it defaults for us but we could
specify the y-axis and we ask for bars
here we are linking rank to the x-axis
we're linking the color The Fill color
of the bars to gender
to sex
and we're asking for bars and so adding
this field equals x automatically gives
us what's called the Stacked bar chart
we can look at this and we can see wow
this university has an awful lot of full
professors
um they have about equal amount of
assistant and associate professors
and mainly they've got men
uh a few more women fall professors than
assistant or associate
if we use the position option
position specifies whether you want the
graph the bars to be stacked on top of
each other which is the default so I
could have said position equals stack
or position equals Dodge puts them side
by side
or what I think is very useful is
position equals fill which makes the
height of each bar a hundred percent and
this kind of graph it's called the
spinal gram
actually it'd only be really technically
a spinal gram if I made the width
relative to the number of Faculty
members so if the widths of the bars
were different but basically if we have
a filled
stack bar chart then it's a lot easier
to see from this graph than from this
graph
that relative to the number of people
within each rank there's a lot fewer
women for professors
that's bar charts let's go on to when
you have available we want to look at
that's quantitative instead of
categorical
so if you have a quantitative variable
like salary for example you could create
a histogram again the same Gigi plot
statement again we're mapping
salary to the x-axis
again we don't have to specify the
y-axis in this case because it's going
to default to frequency count
and we ask for a histogramming
and we'll get something that looks like
this and we can see well it looks like
um you know most of the faculty are
making around a hundred thousand
um some poor poor faculty you're making
around 50 000 and now we've got a couple
faculty here they're making more than
two hundred thousand so my first
question is who are these people and how
come they're making so much more money
than I am
some common options for the histogram
function geomhistogram would be the
bandwidth you know how how wide are
these bars
how many bars are there the number of
bins the color which again remember is
the border and then the fill which is
the color of these bars if we wanted to
we could create frequency polygons we
just change geome histogram to geom
freak polygon and you could think
basically of a frequency polygon as
taking the midpoint at the top of each
bar
and just connecting them as a line
so a bit of a smoothed out histogram
now one and again these are some of the
common options
one of the nice things about frequency
polygons is
that when they overlap they're still
easy to read
so here's the frequency polygon for
assistant associate and fall professor
what I did was I create the width of the
lines by saying size equals two the
default is one and I changed I mapped
the color to the rank it'll
automatically give me a legend and now I
can see
the spread here
now frequency polygons are okay but I
personally prefer to use density plots
so this is an example of a density plot
and you could think of it as a very
smooth histogram
and we can see the shape of the
distribution while I'm doing the same
Geo density and I decided to fill it
with red
and the way that you read this you can
look at this y-axis and you can go what
is this density
well think of it this way the area under
this curve is equal to 1.
and if we want to know how many faculty
are making between 150
000 and 250 000 we do a vertical line up
from 150 000 vertical line up from 200
000 and this area here between 150 and
200 000 is going to be some percentage
of one
and so the amount under the curve
between two points is how many cases
fall within that range the common
options again are fill in color but also
alpha alpha which is available for all
these geomes is transparency the degree
of transparency
so if I want to plot a density plot for
salaries for assistant associate full
professor
and I don't want them to overlap so that
I can't read them I can make the alpha
equal say 0.3 now Alpha of one is
perfectly opaque which is the default
and Alpha of zero is perfectly
transparent so it doesn't show up on the
graph and 0.3 is pretty transparent and
now we can see some interesting things
about this
we can see first of all that salary
tends to go up as you go from assistant
to associate to full professor
clearly associate professors are not
making as much as everybody else
but there are quite a few associate
professors that are making less money
than assistant professors you can see
that overlap there
and there's a tremendous spread in
salaries for full Professor some profile
professors are making a lot and some
full professors are making quite a
little
so that's something we're going to want
to investigate this is called the kernel
density plot for multiple groups and I
find it very useful for comparing groups
on quantitative outcomes probably more
well known than a density chart is box
plug
box plots are a way of describing the
distribution of a quantitative variable
and we just change it to Geo box plot
here now here we do have to specify the
Y value we didn't have to on the density
but from this point on we've we're going
to be specifying the Y value we want the
rank to be mapped to the x-axis we want
salary to be mapped to the y-axis and we
want box plots and in a box plot
the center dark line is the median for
that group the upper line in the box is
the 75th percentile the lower line in
the Box the 25th percentile and you've
got 50 percent of the data within the
Box these hinges or these lines that are
coming off the top and the bottom of the
box plot
capture the knife basically in a normal
distribution will capture about 99 of
the data
and so any points that are outside of
these
lines represent outliers and so we've
got three faculty members that are full
professors that are making way more than
you'd expect or way more than uh
everybody else and you probably want to
ask why my guess is they work in the
medical school or something or have big
grants or something like that
the width of the box plot has no impact
it doesn't mean anything which means
that you can get a lot of box plots in a
single graph if you wanted to compare
the distribution of 10 different groups
on some outcome you could easily put
that into a graph and not worry about
the graph getting too busy a strip plot
is basically a scatter plot so here
we're mapping
salary to the x-axis and rank to the
y-axis and we can see each point
represents
a faculty member
and we can see the distribution of
points in this strip plot we ask for
geompoint to see the plot points
and they're in straight lines because
you know it's really just a categorical
variable over here on the y-axis
and there's a lot of overlap so we don't
really know how many faculty are
represented in this dark patch here we
can change the color and the
transparency and we can change the shape
of the points which we'll see in a
couple minutes the size of the points
and we can also Jitter
this is a bit easier to see the
distribution so what is deutering Jitter
adds a random value to the y-axis a
small random value remember the Y
doesn't really mean anything you know
because full professors are up here
associate professors are in the middle
assistant professors are down below but
other than that why doesn't mean
anything and so adding a little
randomness
makes it easier to see the points that
are overlapping
and we can see the spread of the data
and this would even be a little bit
cleaner and easier to see if we made
Professor points red and associate
professor blue and assistant professor
green and then this would be really easy
to see and to do that we would just add
color equals rank
here in the aesthetic scatter plot we're
starting with a data set we put let's
look at the relationship between years
of experience and salary so we'll put
years of experience on the x-axis salary
on the y-axis and we'll ask for points
and we can see that basically it looks
like the more you the more time you've
been out since you graduated the more
money that you make but then down here
around once you've been out of school
for about 40 years which would be me
salaries tend to go down
so we're going to want to ask why that
is
and things you can change or things
we've seen before these are just filled
circles for the points but we could
change that to any shape we want
by specifying a number to represent a
different shape
we can also add
mine's that best fit
so here's the relationship between years
of experience and salary but we've added
in a smoothed curve this is a low S
curve it's a non-parametric line at Best
Fit basically think about taking small
sections of the graph and drawing
Straight Lines within those sections and
then smoothing it out
and the default is this smooth line and
the line the smooth line is the blue
line and then the gray portion is a 95
confidence interval and so we can see
that the relationship between years of
experience and salary really isn't
linear it's not just that the longer
you've been out of school the more money
you make
but it really tends to go down after
you've been out of school for a while
now I would argue and I don't know this
for a fact that what we're seeing is
that people that were hired a long time
ago were hired at a particular salary
and they make it a cost of living
increase every year but if they're
if their duties haven't changed you
don't see big jumps in their salary you
usually get a big jump in your salary
when what you're doing changes in a job
and so the people that were hired a long
time ago
got increments from when they were hired
but it really isn't the same as people
that are being hired these days
rather than getting paid a lot more
that's just my guess about what's going
on if we wanted to use a straight line
to best fit we could specify the method
LM stands for linear model or basically
linear regression and then we would
specify a formula here we're specifying
a linear line Y is a function of X now
the Y and the X have nothing to do with
variables that are in the data set they
just represent the Y and x-axis so we
could do y plus X Y is a function of x
and x squared X Plus X cubed so
basically if we said poly X comma 2 that
would give us a quadratic fit a line
with one Bend in it
and we could say poly3 which would give
us a line with two bends in it Etc so
the next thing to talk about in
understanding ggplot is grouping
and in grouping what happens is you're
representing several groups in one graph
and you're distinguishing among the
groups by some aspect of that graph such
as color shape size or transparency
so for example
here this is grouping we're we're doing
um years of experience by salary
and we're specifying that the
rank should be rated to the color of the
point and it picks these Colors by
default
and we're asking for points that would
be grouping the alternative would be
creating three side-by-side graphs one
for assistant one for associate one for
professors
here is an example of grouping where
we're using both color and shape to
distinguish the groups notice that when
we said color equals rank
uh we got blue green and red for Rank
and we got it's hard to see but that
circles and triangles
for
um
for males and females I don't recommend
this kind of graph that's kind of hard
to read by shape
at least with points this size if we
were to do both color and shape as the
rank
we'll get a collapse of we won't get two
separate Legends so Gigi plot will try
to collapse the Legends as much as
possible
so now we have different colors and
shapes to represent rank facets are
where you represent the results of
different groups as small graphs that
are lined up in some kind of Matrix
so as an example
here is
the relationship of years of experience
and salary for females versus males
and the way we get this is with the
facet grid function so everything's the
same but we add facet grid and we
specify
period tilde sex
this is Rose tilde columns well since
we're not adding any rows we just use a
period as a placeholder and we get a
column for males and a column for
females
if I had said c
ereal I would get a graph for males on
top and a guide me graph for females on
top and a graph for female for me else
below
and if we specify both for example
here's the plot of urison's PhD and
salary separate we've got males and
females representing rows
and we've got
assistant associate and full professors
representing the columns and so we get a
grid two by three rows by column